100 years ago this week arthur balfour
the british foreign secretary penned a
letter that would change the face of the
Middle East the letter published on
November 2nd 1917 led to the creation of
the State of Israel and would spark
almost a century of conflict
the American colony hotel has hosted
guests in Jerusalem for over a century
[Music]
welcome this place has a unique
perspective on the region's history
because it's played a part in it
presidents and peacemakers spies and
journalists use this space often in
secret to hatch plans and discuss the
future
[Music]
history was made in this room for 16th
this room is very important because we
have the peace process starting from
here yeah and this is not a unique room
Tony Blair used this room to advance the
peace process and this is the patio
where the talks took place the hotel
sits close to the former border
separating East from West Jerusalem
today the whole city is under Israeli
rule but Jews and Arabs are still
divided
this place is a haven from the troubles
all around Jeremy and aphid have both
worked here for more than 30 years one
of the joys of working in the colonies
meeting all the wonderful people I work
with and the things we share one of the
things that Matt and I share is a
birthday
Jeremy Berkovitz is the hotel's chief
financial officer he is in Israeli it's
different
inside the american-canadian outside the
hotel because here we are like we are
working together Hamid Chicana is the
head of housekeeping he is a Palestinian
Balfour's letter has had a profound
impact on both of these men they live on
opposite sides of Israel's security
barrier the letters crucial Klaus read
His Majesty's Government views with
favor the establishment in Palestine of
a national home for the Jewish people as
it also warned it being clearly
understood that nothing shall be done
which may prejudice the civil and
religious rights of existing non-jewish
communities in Palestine
here in the hotels archive Jeremy and
Ahmed for the lettuce legacy very
differently what's this cartoon this is
built for ya when he came here to
Jerusalem to meet the religious people
Jesus and Muhammad and they told him you
are not welcome here
to this land so basically the point is
the Arabs were saying Bofors no good for
them yes but it was good for us as
honest as he was opening the door you
are right the future the letter was a
declaration of support for Zionists who
wanted to create a Jewish state in the
calf up of the Ottoman Empire after the
first world war the League of Nations
gave Britain a mandate to rule Palestine
but the Arabs who had been living in
Palestine for centuries turned
increasingly to resistance and violence
culminating in a revolt in 1936
we were peaceful people till the bell
for declaration came they give our lands
to the Jewish and there is no justice
for the Palestinian this is our land for
thousands of years we've been waiting
all the time for our rights to be
respected as they crushed the uprising
the British tried to win over the Arabs
by restricting Jewish ambitions we're
talking about getting angry I mean II in
1939 when the second world wars breaking
out and the Jews have being killed in
all of your own Britain at that point
says no more immigration into mandatory
Palestine which means that the Jews have
got nowhere to go
just when they thought they would have
somewhere to go so the Jews got very
angry with the British Jewish anger also
turned violence the British gave up and
handed the problem over to the United
Nations
in 1947 the UN voted to partition
Palestine but the Arabs rejected this
and fighting broke out every page we go
to here's got more pictures of death and
destruction and it was clearly untenable
this is a burnt-out Jewish out of
shelter offices right next to the
American colony hotel as the last
British soldiers left Palestine in May
1948 the moment had come for the Jews
they declared the State of Israel
neighbouring Arab countries invaded
immediately
in the armistice of 1949 Israel and Arab
states divided up the land but there was
no Palestinian state just two regions
controlled by Egypt and Jordan now known
as the West Bank and Gaza an estimated
700,000 Palestinians fled or were pushed
out of their homes they called this the
Nakba a catastrophe they took our land
we loved this land this is our land for
for our families the arts are very angry
because they lost everything you can see
since then there have been Wars
uprisings terrorist attacks and
diplomatic deals
nothing has boat's lasting peace or a
State for the Palestinians since the war
of 1967 many Palestinians now live in
the West Bank under permanent Israeli
occupation cut off by the Israeli
security barrier they have autonomy in
big cities and towns but are surrounded
by Jewish settlements others are locked
away in the Gaza Strip the scene of
repeated Wars
[Music]
a Centurion from Lord Balfour's letter
his 67 words have left a profound but
mixed legacy the Holocaust convinced the
West and probably the whole world that
the Jews did need somewhere they were
safe my father lost most of his family
my mother excuse me
they get emotional and my mother lost
not her family as well and well I mean
my family probably I don't know if that
exists without stated as well we have no
freedom and no state and many of the
Palestinian people are left this place
so they go everywhere so it wasn't good
for us unfortunately I don't think well
for decoration kept it's promised for
the Palestinian the conflict between
Arab and Jew remains intractable the
Balfour Declaration helped to create
Israel but the state of Palestine is not
yet born
you